hey team Jessica Chobot here at Long
Beach Poly hi the alma mater of
Philadelphia Eagles wide receiver to
Sean Jackson now he graduated here in
2004 and he's been playing in the NFL
since 2008 so we know that he's got game
but are his skills matched when it comes
to Madden NFL 25 on Microsoft's Xbox one
we pit him against platinum-selling
recording artist Mike Posner to find out
this is definitely an episode you're not
gonna want to miss GameSpot presents
player vs. game meet our player DeSean
Jackson was drafted in 2008 by the
Philadelphia Eagles he's the first
player in history to be selected to the
exclusive Pro Bowl at two different
positions in the same year and he
recently wrote a children's book no
bullies in the huddle the first in a
series of books intended to bring
awareness to issues facing kids today
now before DeSean hits the virtual turf
against Mike Posner in Madden 25 I got a
special tour of his old stomping grounds
how many of these you know we have a
couple trophies in here state champions
you see the Philadelphia Eagles II made
it in there as well to honored about
that I mean this must fill you with
massive amounts of pride for sure that's
a lot of hard work but like I say it
started here and I was able to have a
great opportunity a great support team
from everybody here with sports always
something that you wanted to have a
career in even as a child or is it
something that once you hit high school
you realize oh wow I'm really skilled at
all this and I'm always you know had a
passion for football
I'm not even for football for sports
since I was like nope I like seven years
old is it fun being kind of I mean
internet like national hero but also a
local hero like it's in this Hall we
were here earlier and you were standing
around and I heard kids walking behind
going Connors yeah I mean that's
honestly an honor to my cell phone you
know be able to come back and see the
young younger generation look good to me
you know it really inspires me to keep
continuing to do what I do
how long at that position I'm at that
spot I just want to you know make the
best out of it and continue to do
positive things
look close because we've intercepted the
varsity football locker room and morphed
it into the Shawn and Mike's video game
playing field the title for today's
competition Madden NFL 25 Madden NFL 25
marks a quarter century of football
gaming with a very comprehensive and
full-featured treatment of NFL football
new run free and heat-seeking tackling
that offers controls team enhancements
and an undeniable exciting play both on
offense and defense for more insight on
Madden NFL 25 I'm passing it over to
GameSpot editor Chris waters mm hmm see
what I did there
pun intended all right Jessica it's like
this there are tons of folks out there
that love to play fantasy football
but Madden NFL 25 is the only game that
lets you indulge your football fantasies
provided their league sanctioned and not
like Peyton Manning delivering a pizza
to your doorstep take the helm and leave
your favorite squad to victory in the
first entry of the venerable series to
arrive on the Xbox one
even after years of dedication to
crafting the finest virtual football
around there's always room for
improvement and this year boasts tougher
pass protection a better running game
and livelier crowds whether you're
trying to predict the outcome of Super
Bowl xlviii or facing off in your
umpteenth grudge match against a friend
head-to-head competition in Madden NFL
25 may not be as hazardous is actually
playing in the NFL but things can
certainly get heated I think you're in
for a fun matchup today Jessica provided
that you and our competitors are in fact
ready for some football today we have a
very special celebrity guest gamer the
platinum-selling recording artist behind
anthem such as please don't go and clue
them me we are very excited to welcome
Mike Posner
so tell me a little bit about your new
single I mean this thing is caught top
of the world features my homie big shine
and super awesome
what do you like most about it well for
me what I really like most about a lot
of people I started out making beats for
Big Sean I was like in his crew I mean
he really put me in the game so now to
be able to come back and do a song with
him that close to me awesome so tell me
when are we gonna expect this new album
coming out I knew I was called pages and
it's gonna come on the summer doing a
probably a couple more singles after
this Nuala my son this idea came out and
it was to make an album and for every I
my soul to serve a meal to a child in
need that's really cool you're our
celebrity gamer have you ever owned a
video game system yeah I did a lot when
I was a kid I was addicted to games at
once Emily had to stop it make a little
more music and play a little less fifa
uh-huh so that finding that balance was
kind of your jam video game yeah I
played a lot of FIFA in college have you
played a lot of Madden I played a lot of
Madden when I was a child
uh-huh like when I was in sixth or
seventh grade I remember when the
Falcons were like the Dirty Birds and
they would do that - this was my team
and the Buccaneers had work done that
was when I was playing a lot of Madden
who was your favorite video game
character as a kid fan video game
character as a kid I think probably was
Sonic the Hedgehog super big Sega player
yeah a Dreamcast my favorite systems she
just gave a Dreamcast
I love the dream team those guys know
the way to this girl's heart he's very
very much underestimated the dream it
was sick it was amazing NBA 2k nice play
out of that I mean everybody's talking
was all like oh well the Xbox it goes
online lalalalala but honestly the
Dreamcast was online first well
just thrown that one out there so it
would you pick Sonic Thunder be your
quarterback if you could choose him as a
character it's he's sorry good is
absurdly fast so I would pick him the
play pretty much any position kick
returner running back wide receiver
defensive lineman yeah there you go he
might not be a accurate passer but you
can run quarterback sneaks and things of
that nature
with Sonic holiday what you're talking
about regards to football I'm at in you
definitely have a shot at this what's he
see I'm playing a real NFL player this
guy knows about plays and audibles and
formations and he's you know who knows
what dime nickel and those things I have
no idea what that is no I mean sports
little words aren't semantics no he
probably understands it you never know
it's anybody's game in virtual world
it's just about how you push those
buttons okay thanks for the words of
encouragement we'll be back with more
DeSean Jackson on player vs. gamer after
this short break
what's your favorite memory from the
football field here I have to say I'm
going back to our freshman year coming
in having a lot of hype you know being
one of the best players on my pop warner
team and actually coming to a high
school like mombi's party where you know
log period I'd miss it or well you never
gonna be able to make it here you're
never gonna be able to start here and I
actually came off my freshman year and
uh you know I made a catch
actually I mean we had a scrimmage game
and I I made a crazy kiss and the end
zone the sport on the varsity team and
then actually they punt the votes and
then I squirt on the punt returner too
so I think then everybody's like well
he's probably gonna be able to make a
movie pretty good and at the end of that
season I got moved up to varsity Japan
to play officers you know a great well
good I'm very happy for your success
that's a great story so kind of more
into my real well possibly your realm
what is your first memory of video games
mmm going back at a techno Bowl I mean
playing Madden yes what is it a slam and
jam sonic playing aw that was like I
used to think of myself as him he's so
fast and ran into everything collecting
coins and all that so that was my
favorite game but now I'm more know into
like NBA 2k and that and things like my
favorite two sports games a little bit
of Call of Duty and things like that I
came my personal curiosity and you ever
play Call of Duty multiplayer online I
get mad like I said I don't like to get
killed and all that stuff I call of duty
so I just actually started playing a
ghost no I did a story most trying to
see how that's gonna play us there's
pretty interesting are the first couple
of you know checkpoints I wanted what's
it like actually seeing yourself in a
video game
is that weird uncanny valley thing
happen yeah when it first happened I can
remember back in college and probably
like when I say like Oh what was it oh
five or six it was like my first visual
of me seeing myself on n-c-double-a and
it was
kind of mind by there's like I always
grew up like no be pretty interesting if
I could see myself in a video gave me
not only on the video gaming I was able
to you know be fortunate enough to be
put on a cover in n-c-double-a so I mean
it was a blessing for myself understood
today still have covers still sign them
and things like that so this the dream
come true almost a blessing so are you
ready to compete in some madden 25
against my crazy I'm gonna have fun with
it are we gonna get it on my field I
guess you know we'll be sitting right
next to each other we'll be able to bump
shoulders a little bit and talk talking
little crap so let's get I'm ready
watch it absolutely have some bragging
rights too because after all this out
sorry I gotta go gotta go show what I'm
talking about
alright guys first time in each other
like week the Shawn Shawn meet Mike guys
prep for this yeah nervous was he happy
how about you I'm just gonna have a good
game man hearing he's pretty good in
matter so just gonna take it a step of
the time it's gonna be good alright so
here's the objective of today's game
we've got a traditional one-on-one team
of your choice at the end of the game
the team with the most points wins yes
that yes all right
to the game
good luck Brett don't need a good thing
I feel like I have nothing in lose you
have a lot were nervous a little bit
I don't think you're nervous at all I
think you're letting me get some the
artist meetings okay
you gotta get zeros cuz I saw you part
of them the other gear ask for help on
that we need a
Megatron I'm moving put the ugly right
now these are were Mike was able to
score a touchdown on his first drive
ending the first quarter up 7 nothing
this game is just getting started
oh hey keep talking so tread Cola naval
a yes sir got hot who's that
good touchdown
sorry bro I'll let you have your fun now
I got to go home Sean found his stride
and after a strong drive was able to tie
up the game at 7-7 it's still anyone's
game
don't like that office right there about
this let's see you go I'll let you back
in the game
valet here yeah
you're not friends in anything brown
sorry sir hey I don't think you're gonna
return this pension policy
Oh fact you might even fumble it ah
hiiii both DeSean and Mike had a tough
time completing passes looks like the
fourth quarter will be deciding our
winner
ha all right hey playboy they play Jack
ah this is gonna go for just again city
practice yeah maybe you know Oh Oh what
should i do should I score should I keep
school I know you said do I also know
what you're going do ah good game in
game
you're pretty good bro the score of 13
to 7 and a very close game I might add
up until the very last second fair
DeSean Jackson is our winner big round
of applause and good fight their thing
is gonna look easy on you all you just
take exception thank you
yeah guys it's been a crazy season on
player versus gamer here and I hope you
had as much fun as we did
thank you all for watching bye